soit positive et soit belle et ça tout
ça mais la société fait quand même on
s'en tenait qu'à moi je vous prie de
m'excuser je pense que je vais un peu
brisé l'unanimisme et d'enthousiasmé
autour de ce plateau mais mairie
[Rires]
je suis je suis assez triste est vrai un
peu inquiète aussi pour la société dans
laquelle on verra demain matin vous avez
comprendre vous allez comprendre
pourquoi en réalité moi ce que je trouve
triste c'est que votre histoire elle et
elle est relativement marquée par la
souffrance je vous l'avais pas dit tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs mais il ya
l'histoire évidemment avec avec vos
parents cette blessure d'enfance et puis
vous avez pas expliqué les raisons de
votre tentative de suicide mais moi je
me souviens parce que je vous le suivez
avant c'est une histoire glauque sordide
vous avez été victime d'un harcèlement
atroces sur les réseaux sociaux et je je
je n'ai jamais vécu dans ces proportions
là mais je comprends très bien qu'on
veuille mettre fin à sa vie parce que ce
que je savais ce qui m'inquiète c'est
que il ya ces souffrances et puis ces
questionnements que vous avez depuis
manifestement très longtemps et à un
moment donné vous apporter comme réponse
cette transition moi ce qui me ce qui me
comment dire ce qui m'a m'interpelle
depuis quelques années a insisté dans
laquelle on vit c'est qu'en fait je
constate et je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs réel que qu en fait beaucoup
de gens se posent ces questions
d'identité de genre etc on sait un débat
médiatique récent mais en réalité je
crois que ça a toujours existé des gens
qui s'interrogent sur leur identité et
aujourd'hui si vous voulez je me demande
si vous réalisez je sais que c'est pas
votre attention parce que vous avez
l'air très sincère mais si vous réalisez
qu'en fait vous participez d'une forme
sur les deux d'ambiance âge médiatique
et qui confinent parfois même un peu à
la propagande c'est à dire que en gros
vous avez on a pendant longtemps montré
la face compliqué de tout ça et
aujourd'hui vous venez nous présenter le
visage radieux moi je pense que c'est
ces questionnements en gros le fait de
croire que la consoude le sexe le genre
n'est pas innée mais une construction et
qu'on peut le choisir je pense que c'est
une mauvaise réponse apportée à des
questionnements que beaucoup de gens se
posent et quand je vois l'explosion du
genre du nombre de gens qui se déclarent
aujourd'hui non genre et par rapport à
la cet été il ya 30 40 50 ans on voulait
déjà c'est une mode non c'est même pas
qu'une mode justement propagande qu'on a
on a un empêchement
le programme est finie c'est
jean-françois on lâcherait pas dans les
glandes c'est ce que je crois qu'il se
met en place dans les médias notamment
et c'est pas une question de mode
rokhaya c'est vraiment une question de
réponse apportée à des questionnements
et parfois à des souffrances que je
trouve si vous voulez complètement
chimérique et une illusoire et moi c'est
ce qui m'inquiète c'est dans la société
de demain si on apporte cette réponse à
tous les gens il ya pas longtemps il y
avait un témoignage à la télévision qui
a beaucoup heurté des gens c'était un
gamin de moins de 10 ans qui qui se
déclare et femmes esseulées je trouve
que
bah ils déclaraient pas femme il l'était
il n'a pas voulu changer de corps elle
veut récupérer le corps qui lui étaient
dues les bains je crois que c'est faux
je vous avais peur d'un bouleversement
series avec ce tome et mais qu'elle est
bel et bien le risque c'est le risque
c'est que des gens intelligents comme
ian par exemple disent aujourd'hui il
n'a pas voulu changer de corps il a
voulu récupérer le corps qui est bon
mais je n'ai compris glaciation c'est
vrai c'est bien mais peut-être qu'il ya
eu trois expériences amères valoir les
grilles mais se fait pas peur je
voulais juste vous avez un message et
vous dit aux garçons peut-être aux
jeunes ados à la maison mais attention
faut pas le faire vous lui mettez la
pression c'est qu'on attendait a ajouté
je voudrais
branche d'olivier est vrai que c'est pas
vrai chaque mois juste raquel pardon je
finissais s'échangent avec rakia au
tribunal s'était on est amené maintenant
non ce que je voulais dire qu'elle sait
que voilà et c'est passionnant mais il
ya deux façons parce que tu as déjà
perdu ses jets a perdu
ce que je veux dire c'est que il ya deux
façons d'aborder la question moi
honnêtement je fais attention et je
constate que quand on dit c'est génial
c'est c'est une femme il veut juste
récupérer son corps je trouve ça trop
facile et je suis pas certain que ce
soit un bon modèle pour la société
olivia que ce soit quelque chose qui
apporte beaucoup de bonheur à ces gens
que c'est trop facile mais c'est moi qui
ai jamais
rien je pense que les concernés par la
question
j'essaie de répondre parce qu'il ya
plusieurs choses là je vous fais pas
dire alors vous avez parlé effectivement
de du harcèlement dont je subis c'est
vrai que ça a été très très médiatisée à
l'époque c'est venu jusqu'aux menaces de
mort sur les lieux où j'allais de
travailler tôt
c'est effectivement une chose qui est
pas banal quand ça vient de la part de
milly milliers de personnes de compte
voilà c'est une chose que font les
réseaux sociaux louis leca bâle 2 euros
de militants lgbt si je me suis alors
quand même oui ça c'est trop long pour
en parler la vie
oui bien sûr oui ou non c'est oui
c'était lgbt oui ou non c'était des
personnes radical en fait des personnes
militante radicale oui d'accord voilà il
s'avère que voilà par rapport à ce que
vous vous dites je n'ai pas trouvé une
solution
pour aller mieux par rapport dont
suicide c'est très différent c'est à
dire qu'après mon suicide je n'en avais
plus rien à [ __ ] et donc je pouvais
faire ce que j'aurais dû faire beaucoup
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps et en
fait si j'avais vu quelqu'un comme moi à
la télévision comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure qui a l'air vraiment heureuse et
tout bien si je l'avais vu 25 ans plus
tôt j'aurais fait ma transition 25 ans
plus tôt mais tout ce que j'avais vu à
la télévision mais terrifiée et vous
disiez vous parliez de propagande par
exemple il faut savoir que des enfants
entrant en fait comme moi je l'étais il
y en a toujours eu c'est pas du tout une
question de mode et où que ce soit une
rançon binaire mais a toujours eu il
s'avère que ces enfants avant vous
n'alliez pas le temps de les voir
grandir puisqu'il se suicider en fait il
était suicidé beaucoup plus tôt beaucoup
plus jeune et on ne savait pas vraiment
pourquoi ou quoi que ce soit il se
suicider son enfance aux adolescents sur
l'adulte parce que la société leur
renier leur renier leur propre identité
voulait les uns visibiliser